ce n'est pas une planche à laver ce
n'est pas non plus une planche à
repasser malgré les apparences
voilà à quoi sert cette plante c'est
l'élément indispensable lorsqu'on
nouvelle vague le surfing
j'espère nous vient du pacifique les
hawaiiens le pratique depuis de
nombreuses années et comme les
occidentaux aiment tout ce qui est
exotique
ils ont décidé de l'adopter
[Musique]
depuis quelques temps des sportifs de la
côte basque s'était fixé pour devoir de
vacances dit acclimater le surfing un
nom mystérieux mais un sport sans
mystère
muni d'une large planche il s'agit de
gagner la haute mer et de la utilisant
le mouvement des vagues de partir à
l'assaut du rivage
[Musique]
ça a commencé en juillet 57 il a
commencé par chance on pourrait presque
dire étant donné que j'ai connu un
américain de passage à biarritz à
scénariste américain qui s'appelle peter
virtel et qui a fait venir une planche
de californie parce que il avait vu que
les vagues ici devait s'y prêter et j'ai
fait sa connaissance je faisais déjà de
la planche la petite planche courbet et
j'ai eu l'idée de d'essayer de faire du
surf il m'a donné les premières leçons
et puis il est parti en espagne tourner
son film et j'ai pu pendant trois mois
essayez de prendre quelques vagues et
l'année suivante à 58 nous étions déjà
cinq ou six et en 59 une dizaine et
maintenant on peut dire que le nombre de
surfeurs double facilement tous les ans
[Musique]
je crois que le surf ici c'est implanter
rapidement parce que les conditions sont
vraiment idéales
d'autre part il n'y a pas beaucoup de
monde alors qu'en californie en
australie il ya deux cent cinquante
mille cinq cent mille surfer et je me
demande même si un jour il sera toujours
possible de faire du surf à biarritz
étant donné que ça connaît un tel succès
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]